I obviously don't need somebody to help
me get in shape but the other guys on
this staff this show the dance could use
then and this guy used to be with
Georgia the strength and conditioning
coach now he's with the Oregon Ducks
he's Ehrenfeld who joins us now coach
how are you this morning I'm ready I
mean you got you got us fired up with
the video that you sent out but tell us
about the 45 day challenge that you
mentioned in your little video well a
lot of a lot of people think mental
toughness is all about dominating one
workout I tell my guys all the time
middle toughness isn't surviving one
workout it's maintaining the highest
level of focused dedication and
performance or an entire competitive
calendar and so the 45 day challenge is
about doing something every day doesn't
have to be a lot it just has to be
consistent commitment to doing something
every single day to help you reach your
goals and be the best version of you
all right you gave us the great rallying
cry where you talk about fill the
sleeves where did you come up with the
expression fill the sleeves honestly man
there's a guy on Twitter one of the guys
that that follows me to comments on subs
names Dave Miller he honestly hashtagged
it at one point after we first got
started like day three and I had the
same reaction to it that you guys did it
was hilarious and I loved it and I just
kind of added it to the attitude to the
deal and then over time it just kind of
picked up steam well I have a problem
though that you always say fill the
sleeves and then I got all these
pictures of you with no sleeves on your
shirt like sure so can you explain how
you fill the sleeves if you don't have
sleeves on well if you don't have
sleeves then its unending you got to
keep growing no matter what there's
never an impact just to give people an
idea of what Coach Feld sounds like when
he's given a motivational speech he's on
some mountaintop in Hawaii just letting
his his players know that he is putting
in a workout
I know what you're thinking you're
thinking did coach Rafael bring anything
other than a purple and a black man to
do guns the 45 day challenge on the
Island of Hawaii
the answer's no no I didn't but did you
hike and I want to have across the ridge
of a canyon to get to this rock in the
middle of nowhere to do Karl's I don't
think so you're sit at home watching
this video on your phone you haven't
done anything have you done the 45 day
challenge today have you got 100 buyers
have you got another tribe have you
filled the sleeves I didn't think so so
before you say anything about my form or
about where I am about the band I'm
using get out there and get a hundred
bucks and a hundred tries and get ready
for 2018 campaign
what's hundred buys in hundred tries
coach so we play a game in the weight
room in my staff and sometimes the
players you don't every now and again
wait it's five sets of twenty and five
biceps and five sets of 20 triceps and
you can't do the same exercise twice and
we make the joke you get bonus points
for using a piece of equipment in any
other way then it was intended to be
used by the person who created it so you
might have somebody doing curls on the
on the leg curl machine you might have
somebody doing triceps on the neck
machine you know and it's just uh it's
one of the one of the games we play with
our interns to help them get creative
and come up with new ways new exercises
you know to meet the goals of you know
whatever your training that day and so
hundreds of tries just kind of kind of
came out of that do your players laugh
with you or aren't you
hopefully both going for like that the
awkward awkward dad phase where they
love you and they're proud of you but at
the same time if you're in public
they're a little they're a little
awkward and they're a little
uncomfortable I think that's the that's
the right balance of helping inspire
these guys and have that relationship
that you need were you doing curls on
the plane recently absolutely wait did
you put it in the overhead bin like how
do you bring weights on to a plane oh my
band's I was actually six to one of my
players on the flight back you got in on
it with me so
[Laughter]
you do a motivational speech for my guys
obviously I work out coach but the guys
on the other side not so much so if they
walked into the weight room and you're
there and it's first day how are you
getting them motivated honestly people
talk about motivation and string coach
me and motivators I tell my guys I could
coach everything but effort now I'm
going to coach effort because you have
to but but if you show up to the weight
room and and you don't want it then then
the weight room is gonna win every time
so you got to bring your lunch pail with
you got to bring your attitude the right
attitude and the desire you know to
reach your goals and to go hard every
day you know because the basic when you
when you talk about performance it's
sometimes removed with the the start
point is effort and if you're unwilling
to give the effort there's nothing I can
do to help do you sound like this when
you wake up in the morning don't like
what like excited like you're you're
ready to go you're ready to fill the
sleeves like you're deed you have to
ease into this what's that mean
like do you wake up and you're like
fired up ready to go if you don't
understand the phrase then you wake up
this way I ease into the morning but but
you're you know you're this way when you
wake up right well continue fill-in the
sleeves there coach we appreciate it and
we love the videos a lot of fun and good
luck with the Ducks this year all right
that's Erin filmed me the Oregon
football strength and conditioning coach
redbull wakes up and has a drink of me I
don't and the phrase easin yeah it's
like doesn't that compute yeah wait wait
what are you talking about I don't know
what that means
yeah wouldn't you create this character
in a movie and it's great oh it was just
funny that dude is awesome
yeah there's some funny funny stuff in
there so glad to have him on hope he
appreciates the fill the
Eve's t-shirt that we have coming up for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]